There are particular regions of the brain that regulate hunger, and tell us
when we're hungry, or when we're full. The most important region is the
hypothalamus. In particular, there is one important part. The lower middle of
the hypothalamus controls the sensation of feeling full. So in animal studies,
when they lesion, or cut this part of the hypothalamus, the animal becomes
obese. Because the signal for being full is broken. So the lower-middle portion
of the hypothalamus controls the sensation of feeling full. On the other hand,
the lateral area of the hypothalamus controls the sensation of being hungry.
Again, in animal studies, lesions in this part of the hypothalamus. Leads
animals to become very, very thin, because they don't know they're hungry.